okay melvina
movina where'd you grow up where are you
from originally i'm originally from
senate new mexico
that's on my mom's side dallas
silversmith
but we reside in oak springs and that's
on my dad's side
melvin silversmith and you're navajo
i'm full-blooded navajo
my plans are the neck edginess long
astonishing
those are my plans i'm a proud mother of
two
i have ten siblings nine actually
four brothers two passed on god bless
their soul
i have sixes five sisters six with me so
i'm the baby of the family
i'm the youngest i was taught a lot
by my parents
two different personalities from both
parents
but combining both personalities that
comes up to
having a big heart yourself
how was your childhood my childhood was
pretty good
i've been well taken care of but always
got picked on
i always wanted to go with my parents
somewhere but they always chose my
brother before me merwin silversmith
and did you finish high school i didn't
finish high school but i did go down
crown point i went for my ged
and i took um nursing class on this side
i pretty much know a lot i know
carpentry mechanic
i can build you house if you want shaq
out here
to those like us natives i'll use
cardboard box
but my two kids are safe they're staying
with my
ex sister-in-law winfred watson
so you don't raise your kids no she
i gave her custody i miss my kids so
much but
with this virus going on i ain't trying
to
harm my kids or my ex-in-laws in any way
for them
so you're living on the street living on
the streets here in gallup
new mexico herring new mexico and so are
you using
drugs or alcohol alcohol is your thing
alcohol
how long has alcohol been a part of your
life it's been a part of my life since
um
high school actually i think
mid school 8th grade that's when i first
got hit up by broomstick by my mom
because we were brought up well
but in our lifetime we messed up
and the reason why i'm out here is
because
i want to show my people i have a home
i have a land i have a ride
i put all that aside to live like my
people
to show my people i love them every
little thing i have this is all i got
right here
what is what is your drink of choice is
it uh
my drink of choice what do you what do
you go to most
hello this is gallup new mexico it's
importers
i got imported from to 505-928
found back in 505 so that's my import
and that's the best alcohol that would
care hangover
and what is that importers but when you
say import
importer okay
and you start drinking typically in the
evening and no i
buy because you're not drunk right now
no i would buy
a half a gallon and it would last me
for like two three days just walking the
streets all night
i hardly get rest but i'm just glad i
know that nobody's hurt
sharing that's just that little sip
helping someone else
that really means a lot and how much
they really appreciate it
so you share your vodka
i'm not stingy you know every little
thing i have i'll give it out
like my last meal and that's meal i just
barely got
i'll give it to whoever's hungry
but i wouldn't tell them to share or the
last drink
bottle or i'll give out pints
the way i make money is
i want to say question mark
sell things but i've been finding
stuff on the streets brand new stuff i
don't know if it was stolen
but instead of
selling it back i give it out
give it to the most person that needs it
like a brand new nike shoes i gave away
yesterday
and that nike shoe was like
over 179 or like almost 200.
man living these streets
is not well i can actually say it's fun
how you make ends meet with each day
how are you gonna survive how you're
gonna keep yourself warm
sometimes people die on the streets from
the cold right yeah
if you overdo your drugs and alcohol
okay i'm not going to beat around the
bush
i was when i first came out last year
and like july i think
august but sometimes last year i
spent almost eight months out here
and one guy came up to me which i
haven't seen this day
he gave me a drink of vodka importers
he goes i know what you're here for i
know what you're about
you're one of them good people he goes
take a shot at this so he gave me a
bottle
i took a shot and
he goes i'mma give you heads up
this don't take it to get drunk
this think of it right and i'll keep you
warm and that was during the cold
and then he brushed out a bob
like one of his drug bugs
it was loaded and i don't know how to
smoke it
he taught me and i'm telling you this
is because you're here for your people
and i said i don't do drugs i don't
smoke weed
he goes just take this and i'll tell you
what it's about
so i took the first hit and not knowing
people were following me
people that want to jump me for
helping out the elderlies and getting
their stuff back
and he told me this will keep you alert
this will tell you be careful this is
going to
give you heads up on who's coming from
behind you
not knowing better actually thinking of
it
and then thinking about our always how
smoke
we look through smoke ashes
and i thought about that the whole time
i was out here i took alcohol and drugs
but i used it in a good way not in a bad
way
i help people i help elderlies i help
them survive
i seen things that i should have not
seen
i could say i've seen the unexplainable
the unexpectable
but i explored that adventure what's
what's the
most extreme thing you've seen in your
time here on the street
my most extreme is seeing
a guy who's the opposite of
a navajo medicine man
i seen him get lifted up off the ground
frozen
and that guy did not like me
the day i seen him get lifted and put it
into ambulance all frozen
i cried and i prayed
prayer means a lot
but by morning the next morning i got up
and
i was like now i was worried about the
guy so much
nice to know he's walking right there in
front of hushong
i just told my uncle to stop i jumped
off
i ran to him i said dude can i get a hug
and he said for what as i seen you die
yesterday
i said just right there we're in between
hijo
and third street i said the way they
lifted you
is that you were frozen dude
i'm sorry but you know
it means a lot that my prayers did go
through because you're still here
walking in the morning
and stupid me i had drinks i had hits
and i told him i said hey guy
i'm not gonna do this i hate to do this
but
shoot man i said it's nice to see you
live
offer him that shot offer him hits
and then he said he was brought back to
life
seeing a lady an older lady get jumped
by
three teenagers
should i go back and i told him what if
that was your mom your sister your
grandma
would you like it seeing it
you give her stuff back she don't drink
she don't do drugs can't you guys see
that and they give her a cut on her
left eyebrow
people think it's funny they think life
is funny
they make fun of life that's why they're
where they're at right now stealing from
other people
you help somebody out shoot god has
something returned ahead of you
i find free things i find brand new
shoes
let's only tell me to pass it on
somebody claims that stairs and they tom
look at you i've seen you out here for
so long and you think it's your shoe
when you stole it
why hang on to something you stole
pass it on
because that person you stole from is
not gonna ever get about
but they'll see another person wearing
it
and for people to be discriminating
being disrespectful the only way you're
going to live out here
you're going to survive is by your own
self
you're being honest you have loyalty
be independent to live on the streets
you help one you shall receive help
either way it works you disrespect
people
you get that same disrespect
how are you going to get respect when
you make fun of a person
if they're disabled if they can't walk
they fall over and shoot you go over
there and lift the hand
you don't just watch them and make fun
of them
that's not most people out here
think they know better
all the dealers they're all gone
now i told him you guys are disrespected
so much that you're gonna
it's gonna come back worse on you karma
is the [ __ ]
is there a sex work here sex trafficking
going on in
new mexico sex trafficking i know like
some of the hotels
they have room for prostitute
and it's my own native girls
but what they get out of it is five
dollars
they get a drink they just get one shot
some
shoot up you see them normal happy
but once they get on that they're a
whole different person
it's like
how would you call it
they're making fun of themselves
but they don't know that drugs
alcohol is making them look stupid
all these girls here they're parents
they don't
not one acts like one they act like
gangsters they act like
you know like they can hurt somebody
but she wants a guy who backhands them
they're the ones crying running
for me as a mother of two i'm proud to
have my beautiful kids
i'm glad they're safe alive
but i am out here to meet another guy
i am out here to start trouble
i'm not here to show love and karen
again
i sound like hey man love you guys
so why are you on the streets rather
than with your children
my children are safe after quarantine my
sister got it twice
her and her girlfriend and i risked my
life
to be out here to watch her the
girlfriend won't take her home
she messed up my sister's face so bad
that her face is
barely healing i tell them i watch over
them they sleep on top of the bridge
on third street
i'm afraid that the girlfriend might
push her off that bridge
and i stay at the bottom looking out
not just watching my sister watching
everybody
walkway is a dangerous place
i mean one person so little
makes themselves look big i say
hey little little big man
i said you don't got no balls to be
treating your people like this
i got guys sent after me i got knife
pulled out to me last night
and i took my sister and her girlfriend
i think don't be around me
but just stay somewhere where they won't
see you and i haven't seen them since
last night
do you relate to your navajo heritage
my navajo heritage yeah i do
i'm a hand trembler in a good way
i'm here to let people know watch out
it's not like in no bad way i
heal people
i'm just glad that i have the most two
loving caring parents
who taught us well
i don't know if i get it from my mom or
that side
but the bond of love i'm showing it
i've seen people get off the street from
my words
i haven't seen them but i do see them
other places
they give me a hug and they told me my
words are
of encouragement i'm an independent
person
i'm not out here to make fun not to act
like a fool
i'm not here to fight people but when it
comes to a point
that point will become appointments
how else are you going to survive they
take stuff from you
and you see someone they're trying to
make you fight
my own people would be like that
and that's not right i'm out here to
show love
caring how it feels to have
love again
ain't nobody showing it
i gave up everything and this is all i
got
i'm ashamed to ask for money i'm
ashamed to be like can you help out with
some change
but damn i'm glad i'm still alive and i
still see my people
like the next day with the smile
people discriminate as other races
will repent when my people panhandle
telling them to get a job
they don't know what we're going through
where are the first ones that suffered
we are the ones that went into our
worlds
to survive we went through the long walk
shoot you might even be navajo too you
don't know it
you have a color of navajo on you
i'm like what's up ninja
but i will show love to everybody
i try to keep a drink on me
because anxiety is not a funny thing
you see people get deities anxiety
falling over people just make fun and
walk off
the guy's suffering the lady's suffering
who does that i would do anything to
live it
lend a hand then a finger
most people say i got your back how are
they going to get your back would they
just run off when you get into trouble
when someone steps up to you i tell my
people i got your front
i'll take a hit for you but i'll dodge
it
see you don't know if i'll throw a fake
left but
knock you out with the right i'll
straight up kick you in your face
without knowing
i'm not here to fight i'm here to live
and care for people
and to see them not around shoot i save
lives
all right melvina well thank you so much
for talking with me
but you might be my native so
i'm glad i did this but my natives i
loved them
but they're my ninjas all right moving
thank you so much
thank you so much and just love you mom
dad
love you delilah draven watson my
beautiful kids
you